all right people i'm back in studio it's
november 17 2021 i'm still dave rubin
and this is still the reuben report
direct message you may be noting that i
am wearing a very very special shirt and
i just want to say right up top this is
not a political message specifically i
have a friend brandon who's been
struggling with some stuff lately
brandon i know you're watching the show
right now and i just want to say that
we're with you we love you and let's go
brandon okay
we know you're gonna get through this
and it's very important that if anyone
sees anyone named brandon this isn't
just about you if you see a brandon on
the street you see a brandon on twitter
on facebook you say let's go brandon and
you're proud of who you are so i'm very
excited about my new let's go brandon t
shirt okay we got a big show for you
today i was in tennessee for a couple
days uh over in nashville i taped
candace owens show and i taped an
interview with her on her set i just
absolutely adore the girl and she is
just she's one of these people she
stepped into my studio years ago sort of
as just like a little youtuber who
didn't know exactly what she's doing and
now she is somebody fully changing the
world and in my humble opinion for the
world the world for the better so we're
gonna post that uh in a day or two and
just had a great time in nashville good
people great food i'm filled with hot
chicken right now i ate so much hot
chicken just absolutely insane and the
daily wire is just building out amazing
facilities over there lots of good stuff
happening and speaking of good stuff
that's happening the babylon b these
guys just do great work like basically
they're doing satire right like where
snl live should be doing satire the
babylon b actually does it right and i
was chosen to do a little voice over
work in the babylon b's newest cartoon
about the ghostbusters we're going to
play about 45 seconds of it for you and
the full thing you can see on the
babylon b youtube channel
do you have a narrative problem are you
tired of dead people exposing the flaws
of your political beliefs then call us
we'll take care of any ghost that
doesn't fit your agenda
[Applause]
got the pfizer vaccine and then the
blood clot exploded my heart
vaccines are 100 safe and effective
blasters
are 100 safe and effective blaster
that was 10 takes it took me uh there
it's great video you can check them out
over on the uh the babylon b youtube
channel as i said and if you didn't
notice yes that was uh glenn beck that
was michael malus and they had a couple
other great people in there so do check
it out uh today we got a bunch of good
stories i'm psyched to be in studio and
i sense we're starting to get some wins
people uh first off jedediah bayla who
was on this show just a couple weeks ago
talking about why she was not vaccinated
you may remember she was a former
co-host of the view i guess she couldn't
take it over there with those harping
shrews anymore she left the view well
they brought her back they did not let
her in studio she had to do it over
skype and there's an extraordinary
exchange between her and joy behar and
some of the other ladies of the view and
we're going to play it for you because
it's just worth watching and you know
i've been saying to you guys that i
don't want to do coveted stories that
are just adding to the madness more bad
stuff about covid more idiots locked
down other people wearing 87 masks like
i don't want to do that what i do want
to do is highlight the people that are
fighting and jedediah won the internet
yesterday and we're going to show you
that then we've got some stuff just
generally on what the democrats are
doing related to climate policy and if
you think anything that they're doing is
related to saving the climate if you
think that these buffoons who couldn't
balance a budget who don't know that
boys are different than girls and the
rest of it if you think that any of
these ridiculous policies that they're
bringing in have anything to climate
you're very mistaken we're going to show
you some examples of that and then uh
there were some great great great great
great that's a lot of great great news
this morning we saw this literally a
minute before we started uh the daily
wire
you know they got involved in this
lawsuit against the biden administration
relative to the vaccine mandates we got
some good news on that front and ron
desantis is fighting he's fighting
vaccine mandates too so we're giving
good news today people i'm feeling good
i'm caffeinated
and i just want to dedicate the show to
my friend my good friend brandon let's
go man you're doing it let's go brandon
before we get to any of that though i
want to talk to you guys about cozy
earth you know one of the best things
about being filmed from the waist up is
that i can look like business on top
while being super comfy below it's true
for those of you who've been working
from home and participating in multiple
zoom meetings over the past year you
know exactly what i mean that's why no
gift will be more appreciated this
holiday season than cozy earth sheets
pajamas or loungewear i really like
their sweats i seriously dig them
they're soft and smooth and they're
comfortable i was wearing them last
night
and that's because they're made from
super soft viscose from highly
sustainable bamboo coziers bedding and
loungewear are also temperature
regulating so you'll sleep comfortably
year round it's no wonder that cozy
earth has become the betting of choice
for interior designers and celebrities
cozy earth is so confident that that
you'll love their products that you can
try anything risk-free for a hundred
night trial if you don't love it return
it with a hundred days for free so this
holiday season give the gift that will
be appreciated every single night cozy
earth bedding and loungewear and now my
audience can save 35 on cozier bedding
and loungewear start your holiday
shopping early go to cozyearth.com enter
promo code dave and save 35 hurry that's
35 off at cozyearth.com promo code
cozyearth.com and now back to me we
should have taken a picture i was in the
sweatpants last night like they're soft
and lovely and i fell asleep on the
couch watching seinfeld a perfect day
indeed okay let's jump right into it so
jedediah bila who again i had on the
show a couple weeks ago she's really
just become sort of an all-star insanity
and i love promoting people that are
actually fighting the machine and she
was once part of the machine she was a
co-host on the view i don't know exactly
why she didn't remain a coast i'm
guessing she probably just couldn't take
it much like megan mccain just couldn't
take it anymore it's very hard to be an
outsider on a show called the view which
was set up to show different viewpoints
of different women but has become you
know a major echo chamber anyway they
brought her back they didn't let her in
studio we're going to play you about a
minute and a half clip here and just
listen even to the tone with which joy
behar uses as she introduces jedediah
okay jade so let's discuss let's address
the elephant in the room because you
were supposed to join you're supposed to
join us in the studios weeks ago but you
couldn't because abc has a very strict
policy uh you can't get into this
building unless you're fully vaccinated
everybody in this room knows that and is
vaccinated but you made a conscious
decision not to get the vaccine now the
cdc says a person is 10 times less
likely to be hospitalized from covid and
11 times less likely to die if they've
gotten the vaccine okay so why didn't
you get it
i have a medical exemption to the
vaccine that's been written by my
infectious disease vaccinated specialist
in new york city that's been co-signed
by three other doctors i'm not a
candidate for this vaccine i also have
sky-high
multi-tiered multi-faceted natural
immunity
very very high that has also been proven
it has been shown and it is
substantiated by letters from these
doctors so for me personally this
vaccine poses a greater risk than a
benefit i'm also not a risk to any of
you i know there's been a lot of debate
about that but i have these doctors
who've gone on record with that as well
so
my point about all of this is that i am
not anti-vaxx what i really want is for
people to make these decisions for
themselves i want every one of you to
sit with your family members to sit with
your trusted doctors and to say what is
the best decision for me however i do
oppose mandates i oppose them on the
fact that
let's look at the science this is a
vaccine that was created to prevent
severity of disease and to prevent
hospitalizations now we can have a whole
debate on that in itself but the vaccine
does not prevent you from getting
covered and does not prevent you from
transmitting oh my goodness
so come on no you've been at foxton
you don't have to listen to me on that
you don't have to listen to me you can
listen to the director of the cdc you
can look at the cdc's website that is
why masks were reinstated for people who
were vaccinated because they said and
they admitted they came out and said
this for this delta variant transmission
is going to be a thing for vaccinated
people i am prioritizing my health and
people talk about the comments over the
health and safety
if you're not prioritizing your own
health
man there is so much good there and
jedediah if you're watching i just want
to say you are an absolute all-star you
just leveled up into the game you were
part of the machine and now you're
fighting the machine that's exactly what
we need i want to go over a couple of
the bullet points of the things that she
says as joy is completely dismissing her
she says that she has a medical
exemption so she's not a candidate and
she's worked this through with her
doctors she has sky-high natural
immunity she says she has a letter to
prove it she says she's not a risk to
them because of this natural immunity
and she says she's not anti-backs right
she's anti-mandate uh she then says that
everyone should make a decision for
themselves if you go back into that part
that's the part that it sounded like
whoopi burped and then
she says that this is where it really
got good she says the vaccine does not
prevent uh people from getting coveted
or transmitting covid we all know this
to be true right now right like gen saki
had kovid two weeks ago she was
obviously vaccinated everyone that i
know that's gotten coveted in the last
two months has been vaccinated i
literally don't know anyone no no but i
will be completely truthful as i try to
be on the show my friend dennis prager
did get covid while he was unvaxxed and
took all sorts of stuff and he was fine
a few days later this is a guy who is i
love dennis but he's a little overweight
and smokes cigars all the time and he's
in his 70s but he was 100 okay but
everyone else that i know that has
gotten covet over the last couple of
months has gotten the vaccine so we know
what she said is true and then she said
uh you can once you have the vaccine you
can still transmit it well we know that
is true as well that's where they
started groaning and joy said oh you've
been hanging out with those fox news
people too much in the audience a bunch
of seals
like it's these people are just
ridiculous then at the end there oh you
know you don't care about people in
effect is what the other one that's
sunny huston what she was saying you
know you have to care about people more
it's like if the vaccine works then
you'd let her on the set and she has
natural immunity and you'd all be
sitting there and there would be no risk
they all know it they're just lying like
they're just lying i don't know i really
wish
that i knew what happened to joy behar i
used to adore her when when i was a good
decent liberal and i lived on the upper
west side of manhattan and i would see
joy all the time and i lived right near
the view studios and we'd chat and i
chat with her husband and she pet my dog
and we'd talk about stuff she was a you
may not agree with her politics but she
was like a decent liberal right and she
just lost her mind and where are the
fact checkers on this clip like if we're
to believe that the fact checkers are
always supposed to fact-check things and
these are very important facts it's like
jedediah said the truth joy lied joy
lied the audience applauded it and
that's what i always talk about this
chasm between reality and what
mainstream shows you so if you have a
whole bunch let's say i don't know i've
been to the view many times i don't know
how many people they have in the
audience now but i would say usually
it's about 200 people i don't know if
they've limited that now but if you have
200 people in that audience who are all
vaccinated and joy implies that oh no
you can't get coveted if you're
vaccinated you can't get it and you
can't transmit it it's like they're all
applauding it well she's lying and then
they don't know that they're possibly
transmitting it to each other and
everything else
we've got some work to do but i think
we're going to do it that brings me to a
fabulous story that i have to tell you
about one man fighting the system and
that man is sitting in this studio right
now and that man is not me in this case
but my producer michael who is within
the illegal six feet of me right now i'd
say we've got a cool four feet between
us right now uh he was coming with me
he's my producer so he was coming to
nashville
to do the uh candice show with me and
and meet their people and everything and
he wanted to get a new shirt for this
adventure that we would be on and i'd
like to say that the reuben poor pays
decently so the guy can afford a decent
shirt he goes to bloomingdale's and he's
a good man he's a man who does not want
to upset
you know the average person so he puts
on his mask to go in the store they will
not let him in without the mask he puts
on his mask to go in the store he shops
for how long did you shop for about 30
minutes he shopped in bloomingdale's and
he found a shirt found a shirt that he
liked how much was the shirt
a hundred dollars he was going to buy a
shirt for a hundred dollars this is not
a gap throwaway t-shirt this is
bloomingdale's nice button-down
button-down what brand what oh you told
me uh all saints right a hundred dollar
all-safe shirt bloomingdale's he goes he
takes the shirt did you try on the shirt
you tried i mean you did everything you
could do when you're buying a shirt he
then takes the shirt to the cash
register
and the woman at the register asks to
see his vaccine passport
so michael like a sane decent citizen
trying to make sense of the world said
you know i don't think that uh i should
have to show you my medical records to
buy this lovely all saints shirt
and they then called over a manager is
that correct they called over a manager
the manager confirmed that they would
not sell him the shirt unless he showed
them his private medical records
so michael did not leave with a shirt
and had to wear his old ratty shirt
didn't no it's a nice shirt it's a
perfectly fine shirt uh but do you see
how insane this is they let him in he
shopped
for a half hour spread his germs
all over the all sides and the theory
give me another brand the uh give me a
brand give me a brand uh what is the
brand that they have it bloomingdale's i
got two guys don't come on give me
something all states they got theory
they got uh vince they got vince over
there at uh bloomingdale's okay um
spread his germs all over the place they
let him in and then only when he's
trying to leave
ma'am can i leave this store can i give
you money can we exchange commerce can
we do the thing that is the lifeblood of
human society
no sorry you can't do that
that's how stupid this whole thing is
i gotta get the hell out of this town
you guys with me what do you think all
right all right let's see what happens
guys let's talk about relief band real
quick you know during the holidays many
of us eat until we're stuffed like
turkeys and we feel sick we've all
experienced that horrible feeling
whether it's the result of one too many
after a night out with the friends or
from the anxiety of accidentally landing
on cnn while channel surfing
nausea can ruin a day and in the most
severe cases it can make us unable to
function for those of you who can relate
you've got to check out relief band
relief bands the number one fda cleared
anti-nausea wristband that's been
clinically proven to relieve and prevent
nausea and vomiting associated with
motion sickness
anxiety migraines hangovers morning
sickness chemotherapy and so much more
the product is 100 drug-free non-drowsy
and provides all-natural relief with
zero side effects for as long as needed
relief man stimulates a nerve in the
wrist that travels to the part of the
brain the brain that controls nausea
then it blocks the signal your brain is
sending to your stomach telling you that
you're sick for those of you who want to
enjoy being active without the added
anxiety relief band just released its
newest model relief band sport the sport
is waterproof features interchangeable
bands and has an extended battery life
as the holiday season quickly approaches
there's never been a better time to give
the gift of relief right now relief band
has an exclusive offer just for my
audience if you go to reliefman.com and
use promo code ruben you'll receive 20
off plus free shipping and a no ques no
questions ass 30 day money back
guarantee so head over to
reliefband.com and use my promo code
ruben for 20 off plus free shipping i
should add by the way to the little
bloomingdale's ordeal that michael uh
went through that i did buy the let's go
brandon t-shirts for my entire team and
they have the t-shirts and you know you
you'll be okay next time we go to daily
wire all right let's talk a little bit
about climate because it's become fairly
clear to anyone paying attention that as
we shift out of kovid mania the system
the machine is going to need more
craziness to further lock down further
control us further figure out ways to
manipulate us further figure out ways to
keep us scared and angry and everything
else and i do sense and i really do that
the covet thing is starting
to
uh i would say close up like they're not
gonna stop with the fear-mongering and
everything else but i think a lot of
people are finally just moving on i
really believe it so they've got to
figure out something else because they
can't have you walking around not in
fear just thinking straight and looking
around and seeing the world around you
and making individual thoughts and
choices for yourself they can't have
that right so they got to keep the
coveted thing going so here's some video
of jen saki she is back after she got
coveted and had to take about 10 days
off she was vaccinated for kovid somehow
got kovid don't tell joy behar that
would be very upsetting uh and i think
what saki says here kind of lends itself
to the way that they are going to
increase the fear take a look just to be
clear i know that's been a criticism so
that's why i said that not an accurate
one look our view is that the rise in
gas prices over the long term makes it
an even stronger case for doubling down
our investment and our focus on clean
energy options so that we are not
relying on uh the fluctuations and opec
and their willingness to put more supply
and meet the demands in the market
man it's so dangerous what she said
right there if you really listen to what
she's saying she's basically going yeah
gas prices are rising so we're gonna
have to do more of our green stuff our
recycling stuff our renewable stuff now
i'm not against green things i'm not
against uh doing all sorts of things
related to say nuclear power i know that
scares these people even though it's
deeply deeply safe and we now know that
and they're trying to close all these
nuclear power plants um but what she's
saying is as gas prices rise we're gonna
have to do more of all that stuff that
we've been trying to push down your
throats with bill back better and our
crazy bills and lunatic aoc and
everything else so wouldn't it behoove
them then to
actually raise gas prices wouldn't if
you really believe that you wanted to
transfer everybody over to green power
and the green new deal and their green
dystopia
although they believe it's a utopia
wouldn't you then do everything you
could to make gas as expensive as
possible wouldn't you do everything you
could to destroy the economy if you're
really saying we have to build back
better we have to completely change
things and by the way this is what
they're saying right they're telling us
that what an opportunity there is after
kovid to really look at how we do
everything in america and fundamentally
change things and you silly silly decent
liberals the last 20 of you that thought
that old joe biden was going to stop it
he has ushered it in more than
absolutely anyone else
so it would actually benefit the people
who want us to get to this green thing
that will never really work and is going
to cause so many problems and cause
actually all sorts of uh depression for
uh poorer people i discussed that with
jordan peterson like the best way to
help poor people is through cheaper
energy resources right but that's not
really what they're interested in check
out my interview with jordan peterson
from last week if you want to get a
little bit more on that but basically
she's telling you the part that she's
not supposed to tell you we're happy
when gas prices go up and perhaps we
would do everything we could to make gas
prices go up and by the way we're kind
of happy when the supply chain gets
screwed up because then that kind of
proves that capitalism doesn't really
work so we'll have to figure out ways to
maybe socialize uh the system right
we'll have to make sure that our
infrastructure system has far more
government involvement and much less
capitalist competition that would make
sense so they're telling you what
they're doing and if you don't think
that's enough we we saw this video over
the weekend i saw this one
this is the minister of environment and
climate change of canada you know we've
been going through this big climate
conference these people all fly in their
private jets across the world most of
them like barack obama live in 11
million dollar estates in martha's
vineyard right on the water you'd think
they'd move inland but they don't it's
very weird uh well stephen bildbeau who
is the minister of environment and
climate change in canada uh had uh
something very interesting to say about
climate and i think you'll see the
intersectional nature of this stupidity
mr chair i would like to say that canada
strongly support strong languages on the
rights of indigenous peoples
and the inclusion of their traditional
law knowledge in in the fight against
climate change as well as the protection
of human rights
as part of this text thank you very much
mr speaker
okay i have no problem with indigenous
people right that's just fine if you
your people came from a certain place
and you're still there and you're doing
your thing but do you see by the way
they combine all of these things climate
change has absolutely nothing to do with
indigenous people he talks about the
traditional knowledge of indigenous
people to fight climate change is there
something that an indigenous person by
their birth knows more about climate
change than say the average scientist
who perhaps has been studying it who
maybe didn't come from the place that
they live on now like most of us and
most of our families and most of our
history most of man's history is a
history of people moving all over the
world and all sorts of wars have been
fought and civilizations have
grown and civilizations have crumbled
like is there anything is there anything
he says the traditional knowledge of
indigenous people
it's a completely nonsensical statement
but they love it they love it again they
just clap on oh my god indigenous people
we like indigenous people traditional
knowledge we like traditional knowledge
somehow it's against capitalism we like
being against capitalism
these people are so boring anyway i tell
you all of this just to say
start watching out for this the next
thing that's coming is the climate stuff
there will be climate lockdowns they
will not want cars on the road they will
tell you to stay in your house and use
less heat when it's cold and use less
air conditioning with it when it's hot
and a whole bunch of other stuff it's
just on the way
i'm going to fight it why not
speaking of people that are fighting you
know this ron desantis guy down in
florida who's basically saving the union
by himself he's basically the one man
standing up against the machine at least
at a political level and i'm being
slightly sarcastic there there obviously
are a bunch of other republicans doing
it including greg abbott in texas and
ted cruz and rand paul and now glenn
younkin and there are a bunch more but
desantis is sort of like the poster boy
to how to stand up to our authoritarian
and overreaching federal government
right now and he's doing it relentlessly
and every day and pretty much in every
facet of his job he's doing it well
desantis had this to say about the osha
vaccine mandate from the biden
administration i do this going forward
so this is just the tip of the iceberg
it's going to get more restrictive
there's going to be more power brought
to bear going forward if we don't stand
up now
and fight back i just think people are
so sick
of constantly being bossed around
restricted mandated all these different
things
we've had enough of it and we want
people to be able to make their own
decisions and so so it is important to
stand up for people's individual ability
to make decisions for themselves i also
think it's just
the constitutionality is very
significant the individual freedom very
significant but put those even aside
what's the practical result of this the
practical result of this is this going
to exacerbate a lot of the existing
problems that we're seeing with the
economy particularly as it raised
relates to the supply chain the ability
to get goods to market this is not going
to help
the inflation that we've seen in the
economy i could tell you that is
definitely not going to help uh making
sure that that this the shelves are
stocked in stores around this country
preach brother preach like that is right
he makes the clear philosophical
arguments related to our constitution
related to what our rights are and
individual rights and what the
government's supposed to do and then i
love how he shifted to the practical
part hey people if you start firing all
of these people or you demand that these
people do things do certain things to
their bodies because you so wish it
whether it has anything to do with
science or not you might do other things
such as
have a creation of more supply chain
problems such as inflation like all of
the stuff that's happening right in
front of our eyes it might have a little
bit to do with people who are stepping
away from their jobs or being fired
because they don't want the government
to force them to make a medical decision
so desantis is doing an absolutely great
job like that's the type of politician
you want who says hey here's how we're
governed right here's how we're governed
here's what the laws say and how does
that then translate into the real world
that is exactly what he did there uh oh
that is exactly what he did there um and
and that's what you want out of a out of
an elected official uh and then we just
saw this literally one minute before the
show
ben shapiro just tweeted this out
because as you guys may know the daily
wire has been leading the lawsuit my
friend harmeet dillon who's a former
guest on the show as well has been the
lead lawyer on this
against the biden administration vaccine
mandates and here's a two-part tweet
from ben shapiro breaking osha has
suspended implementation and enforcement
of biden's unconstitutional
vax mandate for private sector employers
pending the outcome of litigation
against the daily wire and others good
this means that if you're a private
sector employer who has been working to
comply with biden's mandate under threat
of government coercion stop there is no
mandate currently in effect for you
don't make it easy for them fight so
basically the courts have said you do
not have a right to do this we're going
to look at the case and after we look at
the case we'll make a decision it is my
fervent belief and obviously ben's as
well and harmeet dillons and many other
people and all freedom loving people
that the government will lose this case
that the courts will will stand up and
say no just because you have a certain
amount of employees you have no right to
force them to do anything with their
bodies that they don't want to do and of
course on top of everything else you
know the hundred or thousand or 500 or
862
person mandate like this idea that oh
there's a certain amount of people who
work at your company so you have to do
it it's completely arbitrary and
ridiculous i do sit in a relatively
small room with two other people why
aren't they forcing me not to give you
freaks any ideas
so this is great news and that's why i
wanted to cover it because i'm going to
cover the good news and make sure that
you are armed with the good news and the
truth because if we do that that is how
we will beat this thing i am not here to
lie to you like joy behar oh you've been
watching too much fox news you think if
you're vaccinated you can transmit and
get covered
guys part three oh you know what we'll
do a couple comments because you know
we're doing the uh the live chat over at
reubenreport.locals.com i've got helen
in there she sends me your comments live
couple comments before we got out get
out of here bob says he has a man crush
on desantis
not that there's anything wrong with
that great bob like to hear it like to
hear it uh dax says the view should now
be called the singular view that's the
point you know i remember watching the
view the view used to be a great show
actually the hot topics portion of the
view you know now we're used to
everybody on youtube and all these shows
arguing and having people on and having
conversations but the view was really
the first show that was doing it live on
television with a bunch of women and if
you if you go back you can probably find
this on youtube somewhere if you go back
to the original opening of the view it
was barbara walters and she in the
show opening that they would air every
day as the show would begin it would be
her saying something like you know i'm
barbara walters and i wanted different
women of different walks of life of
different ages and different beliefs to
sit down and talk about things and
that's why i created the view and then
they'd show joy behar and meredith bier
and whatever
and the point was they could argue they
could have these differences of opinion
and not destroy each other and yes it
has now become the singular view for
sure uh patrick says support indigenous
people replace twitter with smoke
signals
that would be
wouldn't that be refreshing wouldn't
that be refreshing i have a feeling my
days on twitter are coming to a close
i'm not exactly sure when i've been
hinting at it for a while but like i
think i've sort of become
popular enough enough people know me
it's just such a freaking headache over
there uh that maybe i'll just wrap it up
soon enough uh guys part three of my
interview with andrew clavin i love
andrew i've mentioned the daily wire a
lot today uh andrew is obviously one of
the hosts of the daily wire he is an
author uh his new book not a christmas
story what's the title of the book
when christmas comes thank you connor uh
is out right now he's a wonderful
novelist and and writes mystery books
and all sorts of things and he's just a
great guy just a great guy part three is
up right now on youtube the full thing
is up ad free of course at
rubinreport.locals.com
and my interview my sit down with
candace owens we just sat in her studio
it was so awesome because she's got a
huge crew like they're pouring tons of
money into this and i've just so watched
her just become who she's supposed to be
and we did it in her studio sort of off
the set a little bit it's really cool uh
the full interview will be coming to
youtube tomorrow but it is up on uh lo
is it up on locals right now it will be
up
clip one will be on youtube tomorrow and
the full will be on locals tomorrow so
you can go to report.com.locals
no rubinreport.locals.com
a lot of information flying at me today
uh all right i enjoy today's show how do
you feel about it thumbs up how do you
feel about it thumbs up alright people
see ya